bienvenue dans cette faq du premier coup
la rotation était maîtrisée soigner
contrôle et je suis heureux cela fait un
an qu'on n'a pas fait une petite fois en
question et attendait tu quand même le
meilleur des hommes et je me dis à temps
mais répondre aux questions des gens ça
pourrait les aider à réussir leur vie
alors il faut que je le fasse enlever
tout ça coule comme format parce que
c'est d'étendre sa vous apprends des
choses moi ça me fait kiffer de raconter
des trucs que j'ai pas pu raconter dans
d'autres vidéos parce que le format ne
s'y prêtait pas donc c'est parti à
longvic faq numéro trouvé le numéro de
la faq bonne job question des vidéos les
plus agréables à tourner pour toi à part
voyage des vidéos à plusieurs clins
d'oeil aux merveilles tim commet toi
sinon est ce que tu es proche de
reproche parfois d'être très dévoué à
youtube et donc peut-être d'être moins
présent auprès d'eux alors déjà très
chaude tu as posé deux questions est pas
une mais bien joué s'est passé pour les
vidéos les plus agréables à tourner et
honnêtement toutes les vidéos sont
agréables à tourner je n'ai pas certaine
que je préfère à doter son tout coule
par contre n'y en a que j'aime moins que
d'autres
il y aura deux précisément que j'ai en
tête étonnamment celle où j'ai essayé de
faire du bon dessin à et celle des casse
tête et pourquoi j'ai moins aimé les
tournées même si au final je suis trop
content les aura fait après tournage
était très heureux de ces syndromes
grands parents quand tu es petit et que
tes parents tu emmènes chez les
grands-parents tural mais une fois que
tu y étais trop content bas là c'est
pareil je sais que je suis mauvais en
dessin et clé le casse-tête me rendent
fous ben j'ai appréhendé avant de faire
ça en vidéo puisque je savais que
c'était source de souffrance pompe mais
au final tout s'est bien passé et vous
avez été adorable et ça a été très bien
accueillis donc j'étais très content et
pour mes proches et nacelles bonne
question c'est vrai que je passe bon
après y'a plein de gens qui ne peuvent
pas trop comprendre ça y est c'est
totalement normal mais en vrai c'est que
je passe beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
tafer et pour mes proches c'est vrai que
je suis très très dévoué à youtube ils
le savent mais savent aussi que c'est ce
qui me fait kiffer depuis bas depuis je
suis ado ils comprennent vachement ça il
aimerait quand même concevoir un petit
peu plus parfois il est vrai comme vous
l'a qui avait appelé votre grand mère
depuis trois semaines mais ils
comprennent ils savent que c'est ce qui
m'anime depuis que je suis ado que j'ai
toujours aimé faire ça que ça m'a
beaucoup aidé des périodes pas ouf de ma
vie et que maintenant bas c'est mon
plaisir absolu donc ils m'en veulent pas
du tout au contraire ils sont contents
pour moi mais c'est vrai que je devrais
plus les voir pourquoi tu ne cries plus
dans tes titres de vidéos c'est vrai
j'ai écrit ces articles pour toi
regarder attentivement chat
hp qui est le faire c'est vrai j'ai
arrêté d'écrire les titres en majuscules
parce que j'en avais un peu marre qu'on
fasse tout ça je trouve que youtube
perdais beaucoup en lisibilité à cause
de ça et surtout que bah c'était
beaucoup plus violent visuellement de
voir des trucs écrit en majuscules par
tous et très envahissant et ça me
saoulait un petit peu je me suis dit on
va tout simplement arrêté mais il ya
plein de gens partout dans le monde qui
l'ont fait avant moi et au delà d écrire
en minuscule maintenant j'écris des
titres qui me font qu'ils me font rire
qui n'ont aucun sens j'aurais jamais osé
faire sept sites la avant par peur de
faire moins de vue et maintenant je m'en
fous un peu là bon je suis fier c'est
celui par exemple la vidéo je dessine là
j'apprends à dessiner et j'y arrive vite
fait c'est quoi ce titre
en fait ça me fait rire de faire des
petits trous c'est vraiment la stricte
vérité où c'est le put un clic mais
inverse ça me fait vraiment rire donc
voila tu as dit dans plusieurs de tes
vidéos que tu avais fait de la
gymnastique tu pourrais nous faire un
atr juste pour le plaisir clin d'oeil
il est vrai que j'ai fait trois ans de
gymnastique quand j'étais petit alors
j'étais pas les lèvres préféré du prof
mais palois pour vous montrer mais ce
qu'il en gymnastique je vous propose de
lire et de répondre à la prochaine
question en plein à terre en plein à
terre et l'eau vas-tu sortir cache-cache
2 écoutez journée n'ont écouté j'aurais
adoré mais là bas non mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe j'aurais adoré le prône l eau
mais le sont pas les femmes à bout des
gants quand même vous le disais au nord
qui sponsorise et la vidéo nous a un peu
lâché je lui avoue beaucoup mais à la
recherche d'un mode sponsors parce que
elle coûte cher à produire minérale
cette vidéo au pire on la fera sans
sponsors et du coup j'ai très mal connue
parce que j'ai beaucoup de soin pour la
tête et l'autre à partir ses forges
passer pour un débile mais j'avoue je
suis pas peu fier mais à terre tous ont
ressenti par rapport à ton évolution
personnelle sur youtube
ah bah je suis le meilleur non mais je
suis le meilleur quoi c'est une question
très sérieuse et très complexe et je
n'ai même pas la réponse mais je pense
que ce dont je suis le plus content
c'est de me faire qui fait plus que
jamais ça j'en suis vraiment content
parce qu'il ya une longue période sur
youtube où je me forçais à faire des atr
pendant plusieurs secondes pour être
drôle alors que les pas du tout envie
heureusement les choses ont changé
depuis plus rien n'est comme avant et
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
tranquille j'ai beaucoup moins de
pression je me fais beaucoup plus qu'il
fait et aussi j'ai moins peur parce que
je suis riche maintenant donc au pire ça
se pète la gueule et puis je peux finir
ma vie quel plaisir
est ce que vous y avez pensé à ça en
faisant sa marque évidemment band
ailleurs les t-shirts devait ressembler
à ça à la base d'ailleurs un petit clin
d'oeil à tout ce qu'on fait une blague
incroyable à quand la marque et sorties
qui ont dit s il faut un code promo ils
vont l'appeler code lyoko voilà je
trouve que c'était sous côté les gens
trouvaient annulé bas chez ceux qui
faisaient cette blague moi j'ai trouvé
génial alors fort ça vous tue contre
faire une rencontre avec des abonnés
partout en france et dans les pays
francophones
alors tu fais sûrement référence à ce
qui s'est passé pour les 10 millions
d'abonnés le petit tour du monde l'a de
francophonic c'était fou intense
incroyable moi j'y repense je suis ébahi
et c'était déjà il ya un an [ __ ] ça
passe très vite c'est effrayant alors
honnêtement je sais pas si je referai un
truc aussi rythmé que ça parce que
c'était quand même vraiment épuisant
physiquement par contre oui c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous rencontrer
peu importe d'où vous venez et il est
possible que cette année je fasse des
petits événements où je fais genre que
trois dates à certains endroits ojjeh je
parle de concerts pas du tout mais j'ai
pensé a pas longtemps à faire pourquoi
pas un petit délire en suisse belgique
et pourquoi pas enchaîner sur le québec
et j'adore les gens là-bas le l'endroit
tout on verra mais ce n'est en tout cas
c'est un truc évidemment j'ai envie de
le refaire
évidemment si tu avais pas été sur
youtube ou plutôt si ta carrière
s'arrêter là brusquement
c'est impossible évidemment n'en sort
pas c'est sûr ça peut arriver très très
vite qu'est ce que tu ferais alors du
coup il ya trop de questions qu'est ce
que je fais maintenant si ça s'arrête
ou qu'est ce que j'aurais fait à
l'époque cela n'avait jamais marché à
l'époque j'aurais été vendeur micromania
je vous jure c'est vrai je voulais trop
être baigné dans les jeux vidéo tout le
temps et être entouré de jaquettes de
jeux comme ça et de renseigner les gens
qui me posent des questions pour savoir
quel est le meilleur jeu offrira leur
neveu et actuellement je pense que si
youtube ça marche plus du tout je suis
en vacances pour le reste de ma vie où
j'ai gagné assez d'argent
je pense que j'en ai aucune idée
vraiment aucune le mieux serait que ça
continue de marcher peut-être tu te sens
mieux depuis que tu as diminuer le
rythme de vidéo par semaine c'est vrai
que j'avais dit il ya dans une vidéo je
sais plus à combien temps que j'allais
diminuer le rythme de vidéos que je
sortais et je les fais on est quand même
passé de 3,4 vidéo par semaine à une
tous les cinq six jours pas mal cette
diminution est bien franchement ça m'a
fait un bien
incroyable vous imaginez même pas c'est
la meilleure décision que j'ai prise de
vues sur youtube
d'ailleurs s'il ya bien un conseil que
je peux donner à tous et youtube heure
calée à cette vidéo c'est de faire
pareil était pas tout de suite mais au
bout d'un moment si vous sentez que vous
êtes surmenés et que vous donnez trop
vous êtes fatigué calmez-vous il ya
aucun mal à ça les gens vont pas vous
oubliez vous allez peut-être faire moins
de vue c'est vrai mais bon c'est votre
santé physique ou faire toujours autant
de vue je pense que le choix il est vite
fait déjà je prends beaucoup plus de
plaisir à tourner à faire des vidéos et
aussi à côté j'ai plus de temps pour
trouver des idées des concepts des trucs
comme le hit de l'été faire des trucs
comme la marque de vêtements et d'autres
projets encore car est bon pour certains
dans d'encore un an
mais voilà ça me laisse le temps de
travailler sur une variété de choses qui
sont très différentes les unes des
autres et qui font que quand je bosse
sur une chose est bien quand je me mets
à bosser sur une autre j'ai beaucoup de
plaisir parce que c'est très différent
donc voilà meilleure décision je suis
trop content en plus vous l'avez
totalement acceptée génial j'ai pas le
jeu pas mieux à dire bon t'as percée
dans le gaming dans la musique dans
doublage le film dont j'ai le rôle
principal a fait tellement d'entrer dans
la sape
quel accueil incroyable à quand le
cinéma français
je suis sûr que tu avais des
propositions peux-tu en parler une seule
que j'ai refusé car je suis un piètre
acteur pour le moment c'est une très
bonne question c'est vrai que les
youtuber se diversifie de plus en plus
il a ainsi pris un café de la bd il ya
heavy qui a sorti un album donc je
comprends le fond de la question mais
pour le cinéma
moi c'est pas du tout un truc qui me
botte pour le moment d'ailleurs je suis
nul à chier en acting donc de base même
si je voulais je pourrais pas mais j'ai
eu une seule proposition de philippe fin
de casting c'est à dire que c'est pas à
me donner le rôle si je répondais oui
c'est si je répondais oui avait un
casting et si j'ai été bon ce qui n'est
pas le cas j'aurais peut-être été pris
et c'était pour all inclusive la suite
de camping et c'est eric qui a eu le
rôle et qui a fait qui a joué la voilà
pour la petite histoire ça fait quoi
d'être le premier youtuber français je
mets cette image pour que ma réponse se
démarque des autres les stratégies sont
innovantes et sont bonnes ça s'est
vraiment démarqué
j'ai reçu plein de messages quand j'ai
doublé cyprien en nombre d'abonnés
vraiment beaucoup de messages qu'ils
aient bravo tu es premier gg incroyable
et c est en fait pour être franc avec
vous ça m'a juste mis mal à l'aise c'est
pas de la fausse modestie c'est que ça
m'a vraiment juste mis mal à l'aise de
voir autant de gens féliciter pour un
truc qui est vraiment purement
symbolique et qui je trouve on glorifie
beaucoup trop ça vous a touché et moi
aussi symboliquement c'est fou sachant
que la plupart d'entre vous me suivez
depuis des années maintenant c'est
forcément touchant ça fait forcément
quelque chose ça c'est forcément signe
du temps qui passe mais à part ce petit
sentiment là de nostalgie même que j'ai
eus je vais pas être trop content et ça
va pas changer ma vie du tout donc c'est
pour ça que ça fait rien de spécial du
tout en réalité à part peut-être un peu
plus de pression ce qui n'est pas
forcément très bien mais merci pour tous
vos gentils messages et j'ai reçu des
trucs vraiment trop bien écrit qui
témoignait d'un amour incroyable envers
moi et j'ai été touché par ça est un peu
mal à l'aise aussi parce que j'ai un peu
le syndrome du mec qui considèrent
qu'ils méritent pas spécialement ce qui
lui arrive parfois du coup c'était
bizarre gt gt entre arras et touchant
mais je le méritais un monsieur quand
même touchant mais est ce que je le dis
très bon je ne sais pas après que
miradors et bye bye et exploser la
production de musique tu attires tel un
peu plus c'est une très bonne question
en vrai la production de musique ça va
toujours attiré ça m'a toujours fasciné
mais même à l'époque avec cette zone
souvenez vous pour les vrais anciens on
avait fait les journées d'un geek et
j'aime colosse j'adorais trouver les
paroles trouver des mélodies et c'était
un truc qui était génial qui m'a
toujours plu et avec baba et mirador
ballast y carrément 1
croyable de bosser avec des gens si
forte jordan il a une vraie connaissance
dans les logiciels de musique et surtout
il a il a vraiment il est vraiment bon
quoi il trouve vraiment des mélodies
bien et tous les trucs catchy l'effort
kesa j'en parle même pas et du coup
c'était vraiment hyper enrichissant et
intéressant pour moi c'est clair qui
aura d'autres musiques qui sortiront sur
la chaîne youtube là dans l'année c'est
sûr et certain voilà après avoir de quoi
ça parlera voir quel genre de musique ce
sera mais oui j'adore ça et et c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est un
truc très différent des vidéos youtube
etc
donc quand je bosse là dessus c'est
hyper épanouissant et cool pour moi et
du coup quand derrière je me remets à
faire des vidéos comme la et ben c'est
trop épanouissant et coule aussi puisque
ça fait longtemps que j'en ai pas fait
bref c'est un [ __ ] de moulin à paroles
dans sa faq c'est horrible à quand la
prochaine soirée du 28 mai qui est allé
à la soirée du 28 alors souvenez-vous
qu'on m'avait du 28 ième soir il vient
le soir et on prévient pas attendez
c'est cool je suis invité les soirs il
28 on veut des news est-ce que c'était
bien est ce qu'on a raté quelque chose
comment c'était on veut savoir écouter
si quelqu'un fait une soirée du 28
juillet dit tenez nous au courant [ __ ]
et cette fois partager l'adresse la
dernière fois on était des milliers sur
twitter attendent la dre soit jamais
reçue [ __ ] de quoi et tu le plus fier
dans ta carrière de l'orthographe de mon
pseudo que tu n'as pas respectée une
seule seconde j'ai une fille bête mais
qu natsu serait-il intéressé
là les radios a beaucoup là où mon coeur
bat saut ja oui bien moi j'ai quelqu'un
de présenter bien là mon bureau
[Musique]
bon
pas mal la gauche je l'emmène direct à
la can is dead tu as retrouvé les
identifiants du compte un stade natsu
oui oui je les ai retrouvés espèce de
gros mytho kfar sava s'est trouvé une
prétendante des giratoires penses-tu
faire une seconde version du hit de
l'été
franchement grave je pense que je leur
ferai en 2020 du coup du coup ça est une
tradition chaque été on va faire ça
d'ailleurs j'en profite qui
souhaitez-vous voir dans la prochaine
édition qui voulez vous voir en invité
il ya trois personnes à trouver il faut
bien entendu que deux parmi elles et des
connaissances musicales fait mettez les
pseudo est ce que tu comptes te faire
une autre couleur de cheveux
écoutez j'ai pas besoin de la faire pour
vous puissiez la juge et on va modifier
la couleur des cheveux maintenant et
vous dites stop quand la couleur vous
convient ah oui d'accord le peuple
demande plus de threads te plaît mais
vous êtes devenus des psychopathes avec
les threads vous êtes vous devenus fous
moi aussi j'adore ça allait serait
d'horreur laisserait de reddit
laisserait twitter j'adore ça mais on ne
peut pas faire que ça et on en fait déjà
beaucoup
alors je sais pas qui est le chef de
cette mutinerie là qui est très à la
mode depuis quelques temps mais il va
vite devoir se calmer
est ce que tu vas relire les messages
privés sur instagram écoutez moi bien
j'ai une anecdote folle à ce sujet la
vidéo là où je vais dans les comptes
instar que j'ai adoré faire j'ai passé
un merveilleux moment mais elle a eu de
lourdes conséquences j'ai reçu plein de
messages privés youtuber qui était
dégoûté pourquoi maintenant quand tu
ouvres instagram
il y à ça tu ne trouve plus un message
privé d'une personne c'est que des
invitations dans des groupes alors
qu'avant il y avait des gens qui
répondait à ta story ou qui venait
d'être contactés pour quelque chose et
c'était cool y avait des échanges -
twente qui était trop bien maintenant
c'est que les invitations dans des
groupes et donc du coup les gens qui
avaient l'habitude de répondre au
message perso et basse et au riz pour
eux parce qu'ils voient plus les
messages perso puisqu'ils sont noyés
dans une malle d'invitation dans des
groupes génique et les messages privés
de tous les influenceurs de france je
suis désolé les amis je ne peux plus
rien faire le mal est fait peux-tu
mettre fin à sa faq broc et parce que
c'est toi c'est la fin de cette petite
faq ça m'a fait plaisir ça faisait très
longtemps il ya pas mal de choses à dire
il s'en est passé des choses en un an
mais on fera une autre vidéo pour
revenir sur tout ça voilà j'espère que
ça a été élu du coup la regarder et que
ça aura donné envie à certains de faire
des atr a les moines ont maintenant on
va où je vous parle a lésé profitez bien
de vos vacances je veux dire ça à la fin
de toutes les vidéos de juillet et août
c'est beau et à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo où il y aura peut-être
un thread rodez ce raid aux arrêtés la
mutinerie j ai vu qu un gros forceurs je
pars en à terme à chloé cela il est pour
toi
tu as vraiment l'air d'un boulot tu sais
[Musique]